Today, we're going to be talking here in just a minute about missions and what God has in store for us in the life of the church in the coming year.
And God is doing so many amazing things through James River Church in weekend and week out in the church, across all of the campuses.
Last week, we obviously were home because of the winter storm.
We were watching online.
And so maybe you didn't get the update that we gave in church news.
Maybe you did, but it bears repeating.
because two weeks ago when we were in person, our last in person gathering across the campuses, you need to hear this.
104 people gave their lives to Jesus two weeks ago, which is, I mean, come on, that's amazing.
71 people were baptized two weeks ago.
So much to celebrate.
And just thanking God for what he's doing.
I mean, this week on a cold snowy week,
Nearly 400 people came out during the week to pray for revival across our area in a great awakening in our nation, which means that's powerful.
Can you imagine 400 people coming out in the, I mean, almost sub-zero.
I mean, while the other day it was like three degrees outside, coming out to pray for revival.
And then the Wednesday nights through the holidays into this year, up to last Wednesday night.
I mean, they've been absolutely, if you've been here, you know, they've been absolutely,
on fire.
God is moving in power.
Are you thankful to be in a church where God is moving in the spirit of God is working powerfully?
It is absolutely, absolutely thrilling.
And if you're new today, one, we're so glad you're here, but I want you to know that today is a little bit different because we take a couple of weekends in the year to talk about what God is putting in front of us as a church
to reach people in the Springfield area, the Joplin area across Southwest Missouri, across our state, across our nation, and all the way to the ends of the earth.
He's got an assignment on us, on our lives.
He wants to work through us in power.
And so in order to give you a little preview of where we're going in the next two weeks, including today and on into next week, I wanna show you this video because it's so exciting to think about what God is gonna do through us.
Let's watch this together.
35 years, one of our main outreach focuses has been planting churches.
Last year, we were part of launching churches all around the world.
21 of them were right here in the United States.
On the west side of Houston, over 500 people come to know Jesus.
Over 100 people were baptized.
We've seen over 40 salvation.
People are finding hope, frustration, renewal.
We launched with over 570 people.
We've seen over 50 different salvation.
We got to share the gospel with thousands of people because of your generosity.
Thank you so much for your incredible generosity.
Thank you so much for your prayers, for your generosity, and just for believing in us.
We are beyond thankful.
In addition to planting churches in the U.S., your giving has made a massive global impact.
In Austria, we planted churches in areas of the country that desperately needed it.
James River enabled us in the last year to plant eight new churches in a country where they're less than one-half percent Christians.
We now have more than 30 people
who have found Christ.
We're also able to plant the church in Spain.
And what God has begun to do in that country is absolutely incredible.
Our first Sunday, we had over 50 people show up.
Sunday after Sunday, we continue to see people walking through our doors.
We have people coming in from Asia.
We have people coming in from Central Europe.
We don't have enough words to say thank you.
Last year, we were able to partner with Seed Company to translate the New Testament into 10 languages that had never before had access to Scripture.
2025, your church helped to
accelerate Bible translation in 10 languages around the world, and every single language scripture is going out.
Each and every one of them will have a hard copy of the New Testament in their language.
Your giving has brought God's Word to over 3 million people.
This year as a church, we're so excited to announce that we're going to be part of planting 37 churches and funding vital projects all around the world.
22 of those churchwants are gonna be right here in the United States, including places like Austin, Texas, Miami, Florida, Asheville, North Carolina, and Boston, Massachusetts.
There are 4.9 million people in the Greater Boston area.
and only 8% of those people are Christians.
And that's why we feel called to plant a spirit-filled, life-giving church right here in the city.
Thank you, James River Church, for partnering with Eden City Church in Boston.
In addition to planting churches in the US, we're also going to be planting 15 churches overseas in France, Thailand,
Indonesia and Vietnam.
These new church plans are absolutely essential to the spread of the gospel.
As the majority of these cities have a population that's less than 1% Christian.
We'll be planting churches all across France, a very, very unreached place where there are.
350,000 people are just one church.
In a society that has been closed for decades, right now we see a massive opportunity for the gospel.
Indonesia is the fourth largest country in the world.
Over 220 million Muslim huge areas of Indonesia that for 2,000 years have never had the Church of Christ planted a monster in the city of 3 million.
0% Christian.
We're excited about this next year to see two church plants here in Indonesia.
We really believe we could be a generational way from seeing the whole nation change.
In the poverty-stricken country of Ethiopia, less than 60% of people have access to clean water.
This year, we're going to be partnering with World Serve to plant five churches, each connected to a water well that will give these communities access the clean water.
Ethiopia is the second most populous country in all of Africa.
Clean water is one of the greatest needs.
70% of all the illnesses is waterborne illness.
Over 15,000 children die of diarrheal deaths caused by waterborne illness every year.
These weather projects help us to enter to the community, to start to especially in the heritage areas.
The five water projects that we're going to be doing will all have a church plant with them.
Think of the transformation that will take place.
By partnering with the Ethiopian church, we're going to see tremendous things happen in the days ahead.
And we're so excited to announce that for the second year in a row, we're going to be partnering with seed company to translate the Bible into six additional languages.
This single project
will impact over 200 million people to have access to God's word in their very own language.
One of the languages is in the Middle East, and I can't even share the name with you.
They need and want the scriptures in their language, so you will help a growing church in one of the most hostile places in the world.
In 2026, Jane River is positioned to impact six
more people groups spread out across Africa, South Asia, Middle East, and West Africa.
And we see that 200 million people are going to have access to the gospel because you are equipping them with the words of life.
Come on, let's give God praise, everybody.
That's amazing.
Lord, we praise you.
Thank you for what you're allowing us to be a part of.
Oh, God, for counting us worthy to spread the gospel.
Lord, we praise your name.
We praise your name.
Well, I, honestly, I'm a little bit emotional.
200 million people, I mean, think about that.
200 million people, because we said yes, have access now to the gospel in their language.
Think about that.
A city with a population of 3 million, 0% Christian.
I mean, it's just stunning what God is allowing us over the next two weeks to be a part of.
And I'm so excited about it.
I'm so excited about what God is allowing us to do and the opportunity he's put in front of us as a church.
It's historic in every way, historic.
And I want you to grab your kingdom impact card at your seat right now.
Everybody grab this at every location.
You want to have this in your hand.
Pick that up.
And first and foremost, I want you to notice on the front, we're calling today kingdom impact because this year we're moving from the name missions to kingdom impact.
We're moving from the name missions to kingdom impact.
And actually, here's what we're gonna do.
Turn to your neighbor and say, missions is now kingdom impact.
Good job, South Campus.
Now turn to your other neighbor and say, did you catch that?
Missions is now kingdom impact.
Okay, you got it?
Come on, missions is now kingdom impact.
And over the last couple of years, you've heard us use this phrase as we've prepared for this transition.
And here's why, here's why.
The mandate for a day like today and a day like next week comes from Acts chapter one, verse eight.
Acts chapter one, verse eight, Jesus said, and you will be my witnesses in where, in Jerusalem and in all Judea and Samaria and to the ends,
of the earth.
And yet too many Christians have the idea that reaching the ends of the earth is more important than reaching our Jerusalem, our local area.
But Jesus tells us that kingdom impact begins in Jerusalem.
It begins right where we're at.
Kingdom impact starts where you are, starts in your Jerusalem.
And here's the reality.
If you have a strong Jerusalem, then over time you will do more for the ends of the earth.
If you have a strong Jerusalem, you will do more over time for the ends of the earth.
And James River over 35 years has proven that to be true.
But this is a huge, huge day because this is a day not only where we see God's heart clearly, but it's a day where every one of us evaluate if our heart is in line with
God's heart.
Does my heart, do I value what God values?
Is my heart in line with his heart?
And it's also a day, and every one of us needs to take this very seriously.
It's a day to listen to God's voice.
It's a day to hear God speak to you.
And the fact of the matter is hearing God's voice isn't just about today.
That's something that affects every area of your life.
But today, we certainly want to lean in and say, God,
What are you wanting to do through me?
Because the reality is this.
We believe that God is going to channel his infinite supply through every single one of us to change nations.
He wants to channel his infinite supply through you.
And I would say to those who are watching online, we're so glad you've joined us from all over the world.
And I want to tell you this, that if James River is your church home, if you're part of the online family, we love that.
I wanna encourage you though, I wanna challenge you, that if this is your church home, then you need to be a part of it in every way you can be starting with your giving, starting with your tie, the first 10%.
Bible says it belongs to the Lord, it's the key to God's blessing in your life.
And then over and above giving light kingdom impact, because we want you to walk in the blessing of God and it's so important.
But we believe today that God is gonna challenge you.
We believe today that God is going to work in this moment in the lives of every single person across every single campus to do something very significant.
But I want you to understand how God worked through your kingdom impact giving.
Over and above your tie, how he worked through your kingdom impact giving last year.
So you can open this up right now.
And on the right side of the card in the center of it, it says, how does my giving impact?
And I want to walk you through these numbers so you understand what
What happens with the resource that you give through Kingdom Impact?
And the first number you see is Kingdom Impact support $3,088,065.
So we support currently a record number of missionaries through James River Church in monthly support.
771 missionaries are supported through this house, through the people of James River Church.
Are you thankful for that?
What are different sets of making all around the world?
So exciting.
And every single week we have missionaries call us.
And they're saying, hey, I need technology, or hey, there's an opportunity to buy land, or hey, we need resource in this area.
This is why your faith promises are so important, because it allows us to know that what we can say yes to.
But that's kingdom impact support.
The next number you'll see inside is kingdom impact trips.
These trips are self-funded.
So we have a trip right now in Egypt, a group of people in Egypt.
They all paid their own way to go, but then we supply
the materials and the resource they need to make that trip a maximum success for the cause of Christ.
And so whether that is building materials or evangelistic materials, we supply that for those trips.
The next number is kingdom impact projects.
So this is the churches we're planting both in the United States and around the world.
When we do water projects, when we build a building for a church on the other side of the planet, that is part of our kingdom impact projects.
then the final line is one child.
So as a church, this is incredible.
That we sponsor 2,344 children every single month.
Becky and I sponsor two kids.
And here's what you need to understand about one child.
That one child isn't just a feeding program.
They are giving those kids the gospel.
They are discipling them.
And it's not just the kids, it's the entire family that's impacted, which is so exciting.
But all of that means this.
It means that James River Church last year, and that's you, gave 6,432,806 dollars to Kingdom Impact.
Can we praise the Lord?
Thrilling.
Absolutely exciting.
But that's not all.
That means since James River Church started,
The church has now given 91,712,227 dollars toward kingdom impact to reach the world for the cause of Christ.
It's amazing.
Absolutely amazing.
What God has done, what God is doing, what He wants to do is nothing short of astounding.
And it's so exciting to think about today.
What God is going to speak to our hearts, what God is going to say to you,
what he wants to do through us as a church.
And it's significant, honestly, for every single one of us.
Today is significant.
It's personally significant for you.
It's significant for your family because it's an opportunity to hear God's voice and watch him work supernaturally.
Hear God's voice and watch him do a miracle in and through your finances, something that would have been impossible
He makes possible as you step out in faith.
He wants to challenge you.
He wants to move you beyond where you have been.
In fact, I had a conversation with somebody not too long ago.
They were sitting in one of these kingdom impact services and they said God spoke to their heart and told them to do something they had never done before.
They said as they were sitting in the service, God spoke to their heart and said, I want you to make a six figure kingdom impact faith promise.
they had never done anything like that.
And yet, as they were listening to the message, as they were listening to God's voice, they knew it was Him.
They made the commitment, and with God's help, they completed it, and God has blessed them for it.
Here's the thing, you don't know what God would wanna do through, you.
You don't know what, the big thing that maybe you walked in today and you thought there would be no way, but God drops it in your heart.
because he's the God of endless supply and he wants to do something miraculous through you.
What is God speaking to your heart?
And anytime we hear scripture preach, that's a question we have to ask because Romans chapter 10 verse seven says, faith comes by hearing.
In other words, as you hear the word of God, faith rises in your heart and hearing by the word of God.
So all of us are saying, God, what do you want to speak to me?
God, what's the miracle you want to do through me?
And say, yes, Lord, I want you to do that.
Above my tithe, I want you to do something extraordinary through me this year.
And it's so exciting.
So next week, it's going to be a thrilling day.
I'm more excited about what we're going to be doing around the world than any year before.
And Brandon's going to be unpacking all of that with the way we're going to be working in Indonesia, in France.
You're going to be doing work in Africa, translating.
I mean, think about 200 million people impacted by the project we're taking on.
That is so exciting.
And so I can't wait for that.
But today I want to talk to you about what God is going to do through us, the opportunities put in front of us to reach people in the Springfield area, in the Joplin area, in Southwest Missouri, in Missouri, and in our nation.
Because how many of you know
our area desperately needs Jesus.
How many of you know our country needs Christ?
Come on, if you know it to be true, biggest shout because we need Jesus.
We desperately need the gospel to penetrate the darkness.
And that's what today is all about.
It's seeing God do something extraordinary through us that impacts our local area and impacts our nation, which is exactly what Jesus was pointing to in Acts 1, 8.
Listen to what he said again, but you will receive power when the Holy Spirit comes upon you.
And you will be my witnesses in Jerusalem and all Judea and Samaria and to the end of the earth.
In other words, catch this, kingdom impact starts in Jerusalem.
It starts right where you're at.
You will be my witnesses in first Jerusalem.
You know what?
The fact of the matter is this, when you think about Jerusalem, that's your local area.
That's where God has positioned you physically.
It's your city, your area.
And so Jerusalem for us is our local area where James River campuses are.
That's our Jerusalem as a church.
And James River is reaching people through every location across our communities.
And it's simply stunning to think about what he has done and what he is doing through us.
We're first and foremost,
called to reach our Jerusalem.
And through the years, we've been incredibly strategic about reaching people.
And the reason for that, the reason that we have not let off the gas pedal for one second in terms of reaching our community is that our communities are in desperate need.
Desperate need, I want to share with you just some research on this because I think we can forget how lost the world is right where we're at.
Okay.
The poverty rate in Springfield, Missouri is currently 74% higher than the US average.
Our area desperately needs the hope of the gospel.
Not only that, but, and I would say just for everybody in Joplin, Joplin is not far behind that step.
They're very similar.
The area also has a suicide rate, 60% higher than the national average.
Every five and a half days somebody commits suicide, takes their own life in our area.
This area desperately needs Jesus.
This stat is also staggering.
The violent crime rate in Springfield is 54% higher than the national average.
There is an epidemic of hopelessness that pervades our local area.
But here's the good news.
We have the answer.
Here's the good news.
Jesus still saves.
God wants to use us right here, right now.
And part of our kingdom impact is Jerusalem.
That's where kingdom impact starts.
And the truth is God has used James River through the years in a powerful way to bring hope to our Jerusalem.
I mean, we've seen God save people.
God's rescued people from out of addictions.
He's put families back together.
I mean, again and again and again.
He's rescued people out of depression and anxiety from the brink of suicide and the kingdom of God.
We've watched it advance in this area.
God is on the move, church.
He is on the move through James River, and it's so thrilling to think about.
There's a number of things we could point to.
I'm gonna highlight a few for you in the, out of the many ways that we're reaching our Jerusalem.
One that stands out to me is Saturday Serve.
Saturday Serve is this extraordinary opportunity.
We have each month to meet some of the most desperate needs in our community, serving one day a month, shining the light of Jesus.
In fact, yesterday, our first Saturday serve of the year.
I want you to know this, that we had to bring out extra stanchions because the lines to help the lines because the response was so great as we partnered with Community Blood Center of the Ozarks that is in extremely deep need of blood donors.
We're meeting this tangible need.
They had to call in more employees.
They had to call in more volunteers.
They said their largest blood drive would be about 200.
We had 244 people come through to give blood yesterday, which is the largest blood drive of the year.
Isn't that amazing?
That's your response to a very tangible need.
And we have people coming in from the community to the campuses.
It's so exciting to think about what God does through that.
But in 2025,
We had 4,053 dream teamers serve at a Saturday serve, which is cool.
And then we ministered to, just this year, through Saturday serve, we ministered to 38,818 people through Saturday serve across our community.
I'm gonna add to it because just this year, through Saturday serve, we gave away 260,800 pounds of food and essentials to those who are in desperate need.
We're meeting needs in Jesus' name.
And all of that leads me to just help you understand this, that since we launched Saturday Surf in May of 2023, we have ministered to 162,712 people through that monthly event, which is so amazing.
And since we started Saturday Surf, we've given away
690,000 pounds of food, over $690,000.
Can we give God praise right now?
Because it's him.
He gets the glory for all of that.
Absolutely spectacular.
And you know what?
With Saturday's serve, the goal for us as a church is that as we're addressing a need is to really meet that need with $50,000 worth of value.
So we're going to provide $25,000 in volunteer labor
through serving our community, serving the need.
But then we're gonna provide $25,000 an actual resource to the need that we're meeting.
And so what that means is you could be in part of funding an entire Saturday serve for $25,000.
And right now, I know that God is speaking to the hearts of people because they're some of you.
And as you're listening to the Lord, He's saying, I want you to make a kingdom impact faith promise for $25,000.
I want you to be one who funds an entire Saturday serve.
I'm just going to tell you, if God's speaking that to your heart, you don't need to be afraid to say yes to God because you're going to watch him do something extraordinary through you.
Yet even as I say that, I realize there are some in the room and God is calling you to think bigger because
to do all the Saturday serves through a calendar year is $300,000 and there are some of you and that's really where God is calling you to go.
Because as you're thinking about what I'm saying, there's something rising in your heart to say, oh God, I wanna take care of all of that.
And maybe he's speaking to your heart.
I mean, I'm talking big and he's saying, I want you to make a $300,000 kingdom impact faith promise.
And if God is speaking it to you, don't put a lid on what God would wanna do through you.
Say yes and watch him.
Channel is infinite supply.
It's really powerful.
Whatever God is speaking to your heart, don't be afraid to say yes to him.
Well, God is working in other ways because there's such power as people gather in community.
And that's happening all across the year because it mobilizes them on mission for Jesus.
And that's what's happening through life groups.
So last year,
We had 8,128 people in 571 life groups across Southwest Missouri, which is amazing.
The power of that, the unity of that, the strength of that.
And a certain type of life group that we love, I actually think everybody should go through a freedom group.
Because freedom helps people walk in the freedom that Jesus came to bring.
And there are things that may have held you back in your past, maybe in your present.
And here's the thing, this is impacting people in the church.
It's also impacting people in the community.
And this year, we had 871 people participate in freedom groups, which is so, so, so exciting.
Think about what God is doing.
And then my mind goes to the camp.
If you'd not been to our camp, I wish you could see it.
It's a wow at every level in terms of what God is doing.
You watch the difference and what God does in kids' lives.
I see my own kids.
If you could see the journey that they've gone on and what God has done through that camp experience, it is so amazing.
I mean, God radically works in the lives of kids.
One in particular is Eli Brown.
Leeds worship here.
Don't you love Pastor Eli in Avery?
So Eli's parents at the time didn't attend the church.
He wasn't attending the church, but they heard about the camp and they sent him to James River's camp.
He at that point got ahead and called him in the ministry.
At that point, he didn't play the guitar or sing.
And it was at James River's camp
that God called him into ministry and began to speak to him about the gift of leading worship on his life.
And this morning, he let us in worship everybody.
That's amazing.
That's the power of what God's doing at camp.
In 2025, just to give you a snapshot, in 2025, we had 2914 students and leaders attend camp.
That's almost 3000 people at the camp last summer.
Here's even better news.
595 students gave their lives to Jesus just at camp this year.
Come on, give God some praise for that.
Powerful.
That's exciting.
We are impacting our Jerusalem and the next generation in our Jerusalem through the camp.
And here's what you have to understand.
That the registration fee for camp doesn't cover the full cost of camp.
The price that people pay for their student to go to camp doesn't
take care of covering the costs of the camp.
But we believe in what God does in that space and we believe that's calling on us and it's part of the way we're reaching our Jerusalem.
And the fact is we're maintaining and we're improving that camp year round because we believe that's a grace for us to step into in a way that God has called us to reach our Jerusalem and it's so exciting.
Well, those are just some snapshots.
There are so many other ways we could talk about James River is reaching our Jerusalem for Jesus.
But I want to tell you that in 2025, 3,544 people at James River gave their lives to Christ, everybody.
That means since James River Church started, 90,065 people have come to know Jesus.
Oh, give God praise.
He's working powerfully.
Thank you, God, for saving people.
Thank you for turning lives around.
Wow.
Moby, praise your name.
On top of that, this last year, 1,026 people were baptized.
Since the church started, 22,323 people have baptized, been baptized in water.
Thank God for that.
God is working powerfully.
And Jesus said this, and we're seeing it happen.
We're meeting the needs and reaching people in our Jerusalem and Jesus gave us a promise.
He said in Matthew chapter 16 verse 18, I will build my church and the gates of hell shall not prevail against it.
The church is Jesus' plan to reach the world.
The church, that's why our kingdom impact giving starts in our Jerusalem by building James River Church because that's the beginning of our mandate.
And the progression in Jesus' words speaks to the priority.
Jerusalem first, then Judea and Samaria, and then the ends of the earth.
We start, we're led by Jesus' progression, and Jesus' priority is our priority, right?
Secondly, our kingdom impact expands to Judea and Samaria.
You'll be my witnesses in Jerusalem and all Judea and Samaria.
You could think of it this way.
If Jerusalem is your local area,
Judea and Samaria is our state, our region, the country, the United States.
And we're so excited about what God is doing through us and has done through us to reach the United States.
And I'm excited this year because this year we're gonna be planting, part of planting 22 new churches all across the nation.
This is, and in strategic locations everybody.
Locations that desperately, desperately need this.
Why would we care about planting churches?
because planting churches is the biblical model for reaching a nation.
Paul planted between 14 and 20 churches.
That when Peter wanted to reach an area, he planted a church.
When John wanted to reach an area, he planted a church.
The gospel spread like wildfire through the Roman world, through planting churches.
Listen to what Ed Stetzer said.
Missiologists from Biola, he writes this, nothing has proven to be more effective at reaching and discipling unreached people than what planting churches.
We want to get behind church planting because church planting is exciting and effective.
Jesus said, I will build my church.
So we begin here at home by building James River to recharge Jerusalem.
But then we want to reach areas all across our nation by doing what Jesus is doing, building the church.
And so we've watched God go before us in a powerful way.
And church planting is so effective.
On average, the established church, this isn't true across the board, but on average, the established church will reach one person for every five people who attend.
The average church plant will see one person saved for every two people that attend.
That is a 300% increase.
Church planting is incredibly effective for reaching the lost, and the church is Jesus' heartbeat.
Listen to what Paul said in Ephesians.
He said, at the center of all this Christ, what?
rules the church.
The church you see is not peripheral to the world.
The world is peripheral to the church.
The church is the main event of what God is doing on planet earth.
It is the centerpiece of what God is doing to reach the planet.
And we're so excited about what God wants to do through us because the great need.
Listen to this, the great need in America today is more churches.
It is the great need of our nation.
And last year,
We were able to plant churches across the nation, getting behind planters like Donnell and Vaney.
They're amazing.
They planted your story church in Houston.
And Houston is one of the fastest growing cities in America, but its crime rate is three times higher than the national average.
Desperate need for more churches, but they went in and they planted that church.
Listen to this.
On the first Sunday, 500 people gave their lives to Christ.
That's amazing.
They've seen a hundred people baptized.
That's powerful.
We're so excited.
You were part of that.
It's amazing.
You know what?
The Bible says the Lord loves to see the work begun.
Don't despise the day of small beginnings.
The fact is a church plant might look small, but then God breathes on it, changes the city.
It's absolutely stunningly.
We were part of planting 413 church in Rochester, New York.
And Torrance and Alicia are amazing.
And 413 has seen God move in power.
This is another staggering stat.
On the first day, they had 1,000 people show up.
500 people, think of all the people they brought to church.
500 of those people gave their lives to Jesus on day one.
Absolutely powerful.
It's amazing.
But here's the thing, I don't want to just tell you the stories.
I'd like to show you.
I'd like to show you the impact you've made in the lives of two church plants, including Torrance and Alicia's plant.
Let's watch this together.
My name is Torrance, and this is my wife Alicia.
And together we are the founders of 413 Church in Rochester, New York.
And we just want to give a great big shout out to James River Church and your pastor John and Debbie.
Man, we're so proud of what God is doing on your side of the country.
And we just want to take a moment to share with you what God is doing on the East Coast.
Less than 90 days ago, we launched 413 Church.
launched with 1,005 people, 502 gave their life to Jesus.
We have been able to make a huge impact right here in our city.
Over the holiday, we were able to distribute 10,000 pounds of food to families in need.
Thank you so much for your generosity and your belief that the gospel of Jesus Christ matters.
We love you from the East Coast.
Powerful, powerful.
Now I got one more story to show you.
Because two years ago, you got behind Noah and Maddie Heron in Nashville.
And if you know Noah, they're amazing.
This couple is a powerhouse.
What God is doing through your generosity, He's doing a multiplication miracle through what you gave.
Let's watch Pastor Noah.
He's gonna give us an update.
Hey, James River Church.
I am Pastor Noah Heron.
And I just wanna say thank you so much.
You might not know this, but your church was the biggest giver
to starting our church plant, Way Church in Nashville, Tennessee.
And because of your generosity, we are now just over two years old.
We have seen 1200 people give their life to Jesus, over 550 people, water baptized.
On top of that, this last week, we had our largest attended Sunday ever.
Almost 1900 people came to church this past Sunday.
God is moving.
in Nashville, Tennessee, and I am just so grateful because it would not have happened without your church sowing seed when there was no way church, and now there is a way church.
And so we're just so grateful.
Thank you for being our family in Missouri.
We love you guys.
And we're just really honored to do Kingdom work together.
Let's give God praise for that.
Absolutely amazing.
And you know, so today, let's not think in terms of what we can budget.
Let's not think in terms of math, because if we think in terms of a budget, we'll do a lot less than faith would do.
Let's think today in terms of results.
Let's think in terms of the fact that people are gonna be in heaven instead of hell, that darkness is gonna be pushed back.
Cities are gonna be changed because we said yes to what God speaks to our heart.
The Bible says this, Jesus said, use worldly wealth to gain friends for yourself so that when it is gone, you will be welcomed into eternal dwellings.
The reality is this, that because you gave, there are people who are gonna welcome you into heaven from Nashville, Tennessee that you never met.
There are people who are gonna welcome you into heaven from Rochester, New York, because you gave.
That's the power of a day like today.
Today is about channeling God's infinite supply through us.
Today is a day about eternity and what God wants to do through you.
So I wanna show you a map of the 22 churches.
We're gonna be a part of planting this year.
We're gonna be planting everywhere from Boston, Massachusetts, to Walker, Michigan, all the way over to Redondo Beach, California, down to Miami, Florida, and Austin, Texas.
It's so exciting.
The church in Baltimore is so desperately needed.
Baltimore has a crime epidemic.
I mean, it is out of control.
So much so that when you think about, a lot of people think of Baltimore as dangerous because it is dangerous.
Second, among US cities for murder,
first among cities for armed robbery.
Baltimore desperately needs the gospel of Jesus Christ, and that's why I'm so excited.
We're gonna get behind Josh and Breanne, planting limitless church in the middle of that darkness, which is so thrilling.
I'm also excited because Boston, Massachusetts, Boston, it is the highest percentage of adults of any city in the US who say religion does more harm than good.
They think Christianity is a bad thing.
And into that darkness, we are going to be part of planting Jonathan and Macy Carlson.
This is a James River couple, everybody.
They're going into Boston to bring the light of the gospel, and it's going to be so exciting to watch what God does through them.
We're also in the center of New York, New York, a city that is increasingly more and more secular.
We're going to be part of planting Ryan and Jimmy as they plant legacy church because it's going to be thrilling to watch what God does through them.
Each one of these church plants is going to cost approximately $20,000 to get off the ground.
And as we're talking about it, some of you are thinking, well, I went to school there.
I went to college there.
I grew up there.
And God has connected you with that city.
And today he's speaking to your heart because you're supposed to make a $20,000 kingdom impact faith promise to help plant that church.
Maybe you went to school one area, your wife went to school in another area, you grew up in different parts of the country, and you'd make a $40,000 human-backed faith promise to say, I want to be a part of seeing the gospel established in that area.
But here's the thing, we're not just planting churches to reach our duty in Samaria.
We're also getting behind Christ-centered organizations to make a massive difference.
One of those organizations is Christ in action, led by Denny Nestle.
They are the largest disaster cleanup and demolition organization in the country.
Christ is at the center.
It's so exciting to see what they do.
They've got a fleet of skid steers and loaders and all the trucks.
They've got a fleet of semis and a mobile kitchen.
They were one of the only organizations to be let into ground zero after 9-11.
They were the only organization that the Pentagon led on the property to feed people after 9-11.
It's amazing.
Today, while we sit in church because of your investment in Christ in action, they are at work cleaning up from the ice storm in Mississippi and Virginia.
You're at work this morning across the nation providing hope to the hurting because you gave last year.
And I'm so excited to see what we get to do this year through them.
It's going to be amazing.
On top of that, there are so many other organizations we partner with, including Convoy of Hope,
But it's all in an effort to reach our Judea and Samaria.
But then we don't stop there.
We then go to the ends of the earth.
Kingdom impact reaches the ends of the earth.
And Judea and Samaria and to the ends of the earth.
Though we start in Jerusalem, we're moving out to the ends of the earth.
And next week, it's gonna be so exciting to listen as Brandon unpacks all of what God is gonna do through us in Indonesia, in France, in Africa,
it's going to be stunning.
But that's what today is all about.
That's what today across the campuses is about.
It's you and I listening to God's heart.
It's you and I hearing Jesus say, I will build my church and then saying, Jesus, I want to build what you're building.
I want my life to build what you're building.
I want to be about what you're about.
I want to value.
I want to value what you value.
That's what today is all
about.
And so my question for you is, are you building what Jesus is building?
Are you building what Jesus is building?
That's why this opportunity is in front of us.
I can't be on the ground in California.
We don't live in Texas, but guess what?
I can be a missionary of supply where I don't live.
I don't live in the middle of Boston, Massachusetts, where people think
Christianity is a detriment to society, but I can be a missionary of supply to get behind Jonathan and Macy.
You can be a missionary of supply, bringing light into the darkness, and here's the thing.
God wants to channel his infinite supply through you.
Kingdom Impact Sunday is about listening to the voice of God and asking him, God, what do you want me to give?
What do you want our family to give?
In a moment, we're gonna take out our cards, so I want you to keep that close to you.
But we need to know that generosity and a kingdom impact moment is not just about the people we are giving toward.
It's not just about the cities that we're gonna see transformed.
It's not even just about our local area.
It's about the people who are closest to you.
Kingdom impact, faith, promise moment is about legacy.
Parents, listen to this.
Your generosity literally creates the future that your children walk into.
What you do with a moment like this has everything to do.
Not just with the legacy you leave them way out in the future, but what you live for them in front of them today.
You preach to them.
Here's Becky and I want our kids to live at the forefront of God's blessing.
Every parent and grandparent wants their kids and grandkids to live at the forefront of God's blessing.
That's why we're committed on a day like today to saying, God, what do you want to do through us?
What do you want to channel through us?
I'm not talking about what I can see my way to because this isn't a pledge.
A pledge is where you look at your investments or your savings and you say, well, this, if I add it all up, this is what I could do over the night.
No, no, no, no, no, not a pledge.
Faith, promise giving is giving over and above your tithe, which belongs to the Lord.
That's the baseline you're giving.
This is over and above that to say, God, I'm believing you're going to put a number in my heart that is impossible for me on my own.
But the infinite supply of Almighty God is going to flow through me to see the gospel go to people who have never heard it.
My dad always says, I grew up hearing him say this all the time.
He'll say, I don't want the best I've ever done to be the yardstick for the rest of my life.
and this year Becky and I are gonna do more.
We're gonna do more than ever before, and I'm sorry, it's not.
I'm just telling you, I want my kids to live there.
And we have a choice as a couple.
God, what are you speaking to us?
Now we're gonna step out in faith and do it.
This is a miracle moment.
It really is.
It's a miracle moment because it is not about what you can budget.
If we all get our calculators out,
We'll do so much less than what faith would do, and you'll miss out on the miracle.
You will.
You'll miss out on the miracle of what God would want to do through your finances.
I want to give more than what's possible.
How can you do that?
You can't.
But God can through you.
I want to look back and go, wow, God.
I didn't know how that was going to happen.
But you made a way.
That's why we'll say if what God speaks to your heart to give doesn't unnerve you a little bit, it's probably not God.
Because when you're unnerve, that's where the miracle happens.
Or you say, God, I'll come and step out and you don't, here's the thing.
Though it may unnerve you, you'd never have to be afraid to give because you will never help give God.
It is the way he then blesses your life.
He will bless you in ways that you can't believe.
And you might be saying, David, I don't have what God's put in my heart.
I know, but he does.
He owns the cattle on the thousand hills.
Whatever He's speaking to you, He will make a way.
He will make a way.
You're just saying, God, what do you want me to do?
That's what Lee did.
Listen to this story.
He said, my wife and I felt strongly that we should make a faith promise of $60,000.
That was close to 40% of our annual income and was definitely a faith promise.
As Pastor John says, give as much as you can, as quick as you can.
And we were able to come up with $6,000 right away, trusting that God would provide the rest.
Throughout the year we watched as unexpected events began to unfold, as a business owner, our business has grown substantially.
We were hoping to sell it.
Through a divine encounter, another company expressed strong interest in purchasing our business.
We ended up selling it for over 30% more than expected.
The sale of the company generated
5x my annual income.
This allowed us to write a check for the full amount of our Kingdom Impact Faith Promise and tithe.
We were so grateful.
There's something inside a person that is released when you let go of your finances and trust God with the results.
Since that time, our finances have multiplied greatly and unexpectedly.
We are overjoyed.
We are praising God for his faithfulness, his abundance, and his grace.
It's moments like this that teach you to hear God's voice.
So what is he speaking to you?
What a powerful testimony.
What is he speaking to you?
I love Lee's story because it's a reminder.
You don't, you might unnerve you, but you don't have to be afraid.
Whatever God's speaking to your heart, He'll bring it about.
He'll make it happen.
You know what God could send angels to reach people?
But He's positioned us.
He wants to work through us.
So as you step out in faith, you're gonna watch God make you a channel of His infinite supply.
I want you to grab your card because I'm gonna pray for you and grab the pen.
And at the bottom is your faith, promise card.
You don't need to do anything yet.
But I'm gonna just ask God at every location, every campus, everybody online, because this is for everybody.
Nobody's exempt from this.
This is a church family thing.
We all do this together.
So everybody grab that.
And I wanna pray that God will really speak to every one of our hearts.
Would you hold that up?
Father, we thank you because you're the God who owns everything.
Lord God, thank you that you wanna work through us in a powerful way to reach people who have never heard.
God, right now, I pray faith rises in our hearts.
Push us to embrace by faith what we would think was impossible in Jesus' name.
So take your pen and your card, and we want everyone to fill one of these out.
This is so important as a church family.
So you can just take that and begin to fill it off.
You're watching online.
There's a link in the chat.
You can fill yours out.
One of the things that we'll often say
You heard Lee say it.
The best way is that when you turn in a faith promise is to put seed in the ground.
You want to give in conjunction with making that because that's the way you get a harvest.
And so faith promises are about hearing from God.
And so right now, what is God speaking to you?
And as you look at this card, you'll notice, I want you to notice this.
It says weekly or monthly or annually, whatever you choose, you choose how what God's speaking to you.
For Becky and I, we think in terms of the year,
God gives us a number for the year.
It may be different for you.
You just write that there.
And then I want you to know that we need you to fill this out.
Here's the thing.
If you don't sign it, we won't count it because people are relying on this.
So don't put Daffy Duck.
Don't put President Trump.
Don't do your best impersonation of a doctor's signature.
If you do that, we won't count it because we got to know that it's real people.
But once we've tallied it up, we're going to shred them.
So you'll never hear from us on this.
This is between you and God.
But it is serious.
And so right now, you just continue to fill that out and write your name legibly, write the amount that you're believing God's gonna do through you.
I'm so excited about what God's gonna do.
Everybody's filling these out.
And then at the bottom, it's perforated.
And you can tear it off.
There's some information you can check if you have an address change or if you're interested in the Kingdom Impact Trips.
But I'm asked the host to go ahead and get in place at every campus.
And you would tear off the bottom of the card and make sure you put your address, your details on there.
What's God gonna do through you?
What's God gonna do?
going to be bigger than it's ever been before because he's the God who does the impossible.